freedom is not that interesting in black
america what's interesting is this
enormous power
that befell us in the 60s when america
owned up to
to its past the events of the past year
have elevated the national conversation
around race to degrees of tumult not
seen for a generation
our guest today is no stranger to those
conversations and has been a key figure
in the scholarship of race relations for
decades
shelby steele a renowned author
columnist and documentary filmmaker
steele is an advocate for individual
freedom and liberty
and has been a strong proponent of the
civil rights movement of the 1960s for
just this reason
that movement which was focused on the
individual has been perverted he says by
a move toward government dependence
welfare and affirmative action programs
have only furthered racial divides
he argues these beliefs in his writing
including the popular book
white guilt how blacks and whites
together destroyed the promise of the
civil rights era
now a senior fellow at the hoover
institution steele recently produced a
documentary in collaboration with his
son
filmmaker eli steele titled what killed
michael brown
it's an investigation into the 2014
ferguson missouri shooting
just as george floyd's death rocked the
nation at the time of this recording
steele was embroiled in a controversy
with amazon
over the release of the film without any
clear basis for their decision
amazon had refused to distribute the
documentary there have since been new
developments in the story so we'll have
to wait to see how it all plays out in
the end
in our conversation shelby details his
struggles with amazon and the journey
he has gone through to get this
important film made seal and i also
discussed the rise of the black lives
matter movement and organization
and the reasons president trump and his
supporters are so often labeled racist
[Music]
hey and welcome this is the ben shapiro
show sunday special we're so pleased to
welcome professor
shelby steele the only way to get access
to the end of our conversation we do
bonus
questions at the end the only way to get
access to that part of the conversation
is to become a member head on over to
dailywire.com become a member you'll
have access to all of the full
conversations with every one
of our awesome guest shelby steele
thanks so much for joining the show
really appreciate it
well thanks so much for having me so for
folks
who don't know your background maybe you
can talk a little bit about your
transformation
on issues of race because when you were
younger uh you
really were more of a racial radical you
talk in in many of your books
about you know your views on race and
how they've morphed over time maybe you
can talk a little bit about that journey
i was born into a civil rights family my
my parents
met uh as founding members of core
congress of racial equality in chicago
in the 40s
so i was a core baby i sort of grew up
in the civil rights
milieu that world demonstrations and so
forth and
i went on demonstrations as a toddler um
and so that that was i was always aware
of the
issue of race and this was again when i
was a kid was
deep segregation uh everywhere
across america uh and so i
had was was very was very aware of that
and by the time i got to college
black power had begun to emerge
uh blacks had taken on a new militancy
and i identified with that and i still
do
um you know patrick henry is my ultimate
hero give me liberty or give me death
and
if you won't allow me in and i can't
come to the table and i can't play with
every with everyone else
uh then i will i'll then it's revolution
time
uh and so i i got to that
uh in the late 60s i was the leader of
my student
black student union and my college and
we took over the president's office and
we
uh we did all the things that that
militant students did
uh back in that era um
i won't go march you through all of the
the details but
um i graduated from college i went to
work in the inner city with in a
government
sponsored program poverty programs they
were everywhere i worked in about three
or four of them
uh for about three three or four years
uh i began to see corruption
i began to see people
using the circumstance of poverty
as a means to personal ends and people
started to come to work in
mercedes-benz and to our to the poverty
program
that was my by the time i left there i
had pretty much lost
my innocence regarding
poverty work and i went to graduate
school and
began to live a much more traditional
life uh uh
from there uh but i began to feel
that the militancy was hurting us more
than helping us
uh it's it's very good to have a very
strong commitment
to one's identity uh one's group
identity and
and um and to be proud and and all that
sort of thing
um but that's not an end
that's that's that's good uh
but you have to become competitive in
the modern world
otherwise you will languish in poverty
no matter what your
identity is and so it became clearer and
clearer as i sort of marched through
graduate school and
and uh began my my career as an academic
um that you it was it was time to grow
up
and to join uh america rather than
then fight america that my future really
was with america
um and also by this time
one very important thing did happen
i call this the great confession
and that is that in his 60s in the mid
60s when the civil rights bill
passed in 64 america
effectively confessed to colluding
for four centuries with that horrific
evil
of racism but from president johnson on
down
america confessed to that in the 60s
owned up to it
and i think it is the most
transformative moment in all of american
history by far and we've only just begun
to really understand the the fallout
from that confession
uh the kind of pressures that's
introduced into society
white guilt certainly being being one of
them um
but i i did be i did become aware that
that america this miraculous thing was
going to actually admit
what they'd done and try to correct it
i don't know if that's ever happened
anywhere else in all of the human
in human history uh but it happened in
america
and so i don't think we've given
ourselves
credit for that um and um
but i i saw it i saw a fundamental
change
and that change has only broadened and
deepened
since then it is a very we live in a
very different world today
uh this is not a time for me to be
blacker than thou
and raise my fist this is a time to get
busy and start a business or go to
school get
get prepared to join the modern world
and
and uh live in a free
democracy an open society in which we
can
we have now for the very first time the
opportunity to begin to live
not as members of a race a beleaguered
race but as individuals
as human beings who are free to pursue
their aspirations as they wish
i feel very fortunate to have lived
through this transformation from the
dark days of segregation
uh to the america that that is now
wide open uh before me
so in a second i want to ask you why it
is that while this transformation has
occurred and it's obvious on every
objective level
that a transformation has occurred in
american life
why it seems so hard for so many people
to accept that a transformation has
occurred i want to ask you about that in
just one second first
is politics stressing you out it's
stressing me out also my kids are
stressing me out and this is why i need
a mattress made just for me there's
nobody on the planet like you
so why would you buy a generic mattress
built for everyone else helix sleep has
a quiz it takes just two minutes to
complete it matches your body type and
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you whether you're a side
sleeper a hot sleeper whether you like a
plush or a firm bed with helix there's
no more confusion and no more
compromising
helix sleep is rated the number one
mattress by gq and wired magazine
cnn calls it the most comfortable
mattress they've ever slept on just head
on over to
sleep.com ben take their two minute
sleep quiz they will match you to a
customized mattress that gives you the
best sleep of your life they have a 10
year warranty you get to try it out for
a hundred nights at risk free
they'll even pick it up for you if you
don't love it but you will helix is
offering up to 200 bucks off all
mattress orders for our listeners right
now get up to 200 bucks off at
helixsleep.com that is helixsleep.com
ben it is the most comfortable mattress
you've ever tried because it's made just
for you
helixsleep.com for up to 200 bucks off
so let's talk about the fact that
america has obviously transformed
there's a major difference between
america and circa 1960 and america circa
2020 but the way that you hear
so many people talk about america in
2020 is though
nothing has changed you have
high-profile authors well-regarded
writers
uh pulitzer prize winners like nicole
hannah jones or uh or or
ta-nehisi coates you know basically
writing essays in which they
talk about an atrocity that happened in
1915 and then immediately fast forward
to 2020 and act as though there are no
intervening events how is it that that
has become
intellectually credible it seems so
perfectly obvious that things have
radically changed since the 1960s racism
is the worst sin in american life and it
is the thing that if you are called a
racist it can it can literally finish
your career whether it's justified
or not i mean that's how much americans
abhor racism at this point and yet it is
still treated uh the the issue of racism
is still treated as though systemic
as the most americans secretly harbor
racist feelings
and you've talked before about the
shifting definition of racism itself
maybe you can talk a little bit about
why you think uh racism is still
considered such a major part of american
life despite the transformational change
okay i'd be happy to um for one reason
when there was this great confession
that i mentioned
and america owned up to its past and and
and we created a war on poverty and we
created all sorts of social programs
public housing
welfare so forth the
what became clear one of one of the
offshoots
of that confession was that
victimization our victimization as
blacks our victimization
uh at the hands of broader america
became our power
it was the first time in american
history we had
any we had power to wield in american
life
because america itself had confessed
and so we had that moral authority for
the first time
uh in american life and it became
our primary source of power in
uh in in society we could we could claim
racism
and what could america say they had
already admitted to racism
and so it it became we began to believe
and this is the tragedy of this to take
that
that victimization be became our
identity became the center of who we are
if you want to make bl a black a black
person angry
tell them that they're not a victim
it's a it's intolerable to hear that
because again the idea that we
are victims is our uh entree to
to power into american society hannah
jones at the new york times
is simply reinforcing the old
theory of black victimization is power
she's just saying
look at all of this victimization look
at what you
owe us look at what how you must follow
our lead morally look at how immoral you
were
and boy that's a lot of power it has
transformed
our entire educational system uh
it's we political correctness
uh it's had a trem it's had a tremendous
impact so even though we are now
free uh freedom is not that interesting
in black america what's interesting is
this enormous power
that befell us in the 60s when america
owned up to
to its past and that's what we protect
and the entire grievance industry in
america
is basically is based on that
you owe us our victimization is our
ticket to ride it is our authority
in american life you have to come to us
one of the difficult things is to tell a
group that never had any power
suddenly they have a kind of moral power
it's
difficult to accept that that moral
power they now have
is killing them it's hurting them
a very difficult point to make they look
at me and they say
oh my god that uh you're giving up
you're walking away from what we fought
for
we've now finally have the power to make
universities get rid of the s.a.t test
we can we can do all sorts of
of things that we never could do before
and
and you want us to drop that um
well i do because the the the thing
about
the thing about victimization is power
is that
you become your own enemy you victimize
yourself in the long run
and you get nowhere and so after 60
years now
of using victimization as power black
america
is farther behind white america than we
were in the 50s when i was a kid
when we were when i was growing up uh
so this power of victimization
has turned on us and and is is
choking us uh at this point and it
breaks my heart to go to campuses you
see
young black kids and they're all huddled
off in their their black power
this and black power that and and black
lives matter and all that sort of
uh struggling you see it's painful
struggling to keep victimization
alive as power as the power in the black
community
so why do you think it is that so many
members of the white community
uh have gone along with this i mean it
would be one thing to say
you know back in 1965 that huge swaths
of americans had
acknowledged their guilt because they
had in fact been complicit in racism i
was born in 1984 so i was born 20 years
after the civil rights act and uh i i
frankly don't feel
racial guilt because i don't believe
that i've acted in racially intolerant
ways
but you see huge swaths of particularly
young white americans
who are going along with this and and
brow beating
and and browbeating others engaging in
maoist struggle sessions in which they
confess their own guilt for complicity
in a systemically racist system what do
you think is the attraction for white
americans
to go along with the narrative where
they are inherently the victimizers
what happened in to white america when
that when america confessed
it's it's it's wrongdoing
is that america endured at that moment a
tremendous
loss of moral authority
when you and it's just human when when
you confess
i did it all right i'm sorry whatever
well okay
now you will pay a price um
and and that that is and that is what
happened to white america is that
they they were judged to be racist
they had colluded with evil and so now
they lived under the accusation that
they were racist
and that they had been a part of this
and so
they may they didn't maybe have done
absolutely nothing to justify
uh feeling guilty whatsoever it's white
guilt
uh has no connection whatsoever to
personal feelings uh it is a it is a
circumstance
that you are living in a society that
does not trust you
that has this against you that holds
this history
against you that uh and so
what do what what whites then have to
struggle for and
have since the 60s is their innocence
of racism of proving oh not me i'm not a
racist
uh and that that need to prove
um is what blacks take advantage of
uh okay then then do this and do that
and so forth and so on and change your
curriculum here and and uh uh start an
hr
pro uh program there have another so
forth and so on
uh and whites do it because they want
that innocence they want to be able to
say look
i supported affirmative action i'm all
for it let's uh
let's uh i support diversity let's have
different colored faces on
in everything we do uh so that we can
prove we are
innocent of that historical accusation
that we are evil racists anything
anything to get away from that and so
you know that one race begins to enable
another race we have a
sort of a symbiotic connection a whites
exploiting blacks all over again in
order this time
to capture some recapture some innocence
and power blacks sort of selling
themselves
out to guilty whites in order to
ex to have the illusion that
victimization
is is their power and so forth uh so it
gets to be a kind of
sad symbiosis that we are caught in
and uh we never honestly talk about it
uh but we're all nervous about it we're
all nervous
and and uh we all hope for the best i
think
but it is history is powerful
um and america is has a
very unique history we're far far ahead
of
much of the rest of the world in this
regard
um but we we have a long way to go
it seems like there's something else
that has happened here too and that's
not just that uh
there's an attempt by both you know
guilty whites and uh
and and some black americans to push for
particular policy prescriptions and
sort of gimmies um but there's something
now that's going on that's completely
i think unprecedented which is that
you're only declared to be
not racist for a certain period of time
if you acknowledge your racism
so in other words if you say as a white
person i'm not racist
i'm colorblind and i i see everybody as
an individual this is in fact used as
evidence
of your racism whereas if you then
declare that you
are in fact a racist by dents of the
color of your skin and through racial
essentialization
then you are not racist but you are also
racist because you just acknowledge that
you're racist so it's a complete
catch-22 there's literally no way for
white americans to escape
the charges of racism either you admit
that you're a racist in which case we
say
okay well at least you're honest enough
to admit you're a racist but that means
you're kind of a racist because you just
admitted it
or you won't acknowledge your own racism
in which case we absolutely 100
know that you're a racist that's right
uh and that power the power to put
whites in that position is what
is is what black power is is the power
that comes
from our from our moral authority as
victims as historical victims
uh and so we enjoy sort of squeezing
whites and
and uh in this in this impossible uh
this impossible circumstance uh but it
helps
again obviously whites
do not have at this moment in america
i'm speaking broad
broad terms here whites do not have the
moral
confidence to resist this
to say hey call me a racist whatever you
want
i believe this i stand by this
uh and i'll argue on the on the terms of
whatever it is i i stand by
i'm not going to be i'm not going to be
blackmailed intimidated
uh about the about simply being white
and simply having a a connection to
people in the past who are also white
uh does not mean that i am evil
uh and that i am a racist if you can't
accept that
too bad whites simply do not in america
have the moral
confidence to do that to say that that's
why we're stuck
when whites begin to rediscover their
confidence
and and accept the fact that they are
not
racists uh and that they want
to treat everybody as individuals and
they practice that
race problem be over black power will be
over
we'll have to take victimization and go
home it doesn't work anymore
right now it's just white's just this
morning amazon
castle the film that i i just
am coming out with uh just as they gave
10 million dollars to black lives matter
and other
um left-wing black groups
uh well that's white guilt
they don't they don't believe in the
money that they gave they don't they
have no they don't care
what they they do with it with the money
uh they are buying their own innocence
they're saying
our brand is not racist
if you give money to shelby steele or
you just even put his
his uh uh his film up on on your
platform
you're a bigot you're a racist you're a
horrible person
so forth well i suffer today
from the lack of confidence that whites
have
that now is a big problem in my life
and in my work i have someone who grew
up
fighting against segregation now i'm
fighting against it all over again
so in a second i want to ask you about
exactly that sort of turn where
so many of the things of the past that
were considered to be the the beacons of
hope the things that we aspired to as a
society have now become
the obstacles the the enemies that we
have to get rid of in pursuit of
anti-racism in the
uh sort of pernicious definition of the
ibram kennedys and robin d'angelo's
we'll get to that in just one second
first
it's halloween this month policy genius
would like to mark the occasion by
making something less scary
life insurance shopping for life
insurance can seem like a daunting task
but policy genius makes it easy they
combine a cutting edge insurance
marketplace with help from licensed
experts to save you time and save you
money right now
you could save 50 or more by using
policy genius to compare life insurance
when you're shopping for a policy that
could last for more than a decade the
savings really do start to add up here's
how it works
first head on over to policygenius.com
in minutes you can work out how much
coverage you need and compare quotes
from top insurers to find your best
price
policy genius will compare policies
starting at as little as one dollar a
day
you might even be eligible to skip that
in-person medical exam
once you apply the policy genius team
will handle all the paperwork and the
red tape the best part they work for you
not the insurance company so if you hit
any speed bumps during the application
process
they'll take care of everything for you
that kind of service has earned policy
genius a five-star rating across
over 1600 reviews on trustpilot and
google so
if you need life insurance head on over
to policygenius.com right now to get
started you could say 50
or more by comparing quotes policy
genius when it comes to insurance it's
nice and very important to get it right
so let's talk about what you're uh what
you're referring to there
with regard to you know the sort of
fight against segregation again it seems
like there's so many of these ideals
that
were the purpose of the civil rights
movement of the 40s and 50s and
in the early 60s uh the these ideals
that that we build
you know statues of martin luther king
not because we agree with his economic
philosophies but because
specifically of his vision of
individuals being treated as
individuals i mean that that is that is
what school children learn it's why he
deserves his own day
i mean this is this is why people
celebrate martin luther king on a broad
scale across
the united states and yet we have seen
that the world culture has pushed so far
that individualism is now seen as a
as a hallmark of white culture uh there
was a
display at the national smithsonian at
the national museum of african-american
history
in which they declared that aspect of
white supremacy
in american culture included things like
being timely uh
having a work ethic believing that you
should that you should delay
gratification
i believe in individualism a belief in
problem solving and it seems to me that
if you want anybody to succeed these are
just things that
they need to engage in but according to
the smithsonian and the national museum
of african american history
these were aspects of of white supremacy
and so we have to abolish
all of our traditional notions of cause
and effect of good behavior and bad
behavior
in pursuit of the belief that individual
actions don't matter at all and all
problems can be chalked up to broad
societal discrimination
this is how desperate
white institutional america is
for innocence of racism they will go to
these lengths
uh to to advertise who try to advertise
their own innocence to the world
um these are people entire you as you
say
have done probably have no personal
guilt whatever and yet their
their whole politics their whole uh
orientation toward american life uh
is is is around again
victimization uh and their their need
for innocence
uh they just will do anything to
to reclaim uh innocence it is
uh i remember when i was in my
black militant stage as as a kid
in college and i ran into a white man
one night in a hotel lobby and
and uh just for the heck of it
i told him that he should give me 25
right then and there uh because he was
white and he was a racist and he needed
to pay off
and of course he gave me about 40. well
[Laughter]
you know it's tempting you know the
imagination goes
wild i could i could really fan this
into something
and and open up put out a shingle and
innocence here come and you know we got
we've got a sale
today um but it's not funny it's tragic
and white america
is lost to this the the young are just
preoccupied with this
this idea of establishing their
innocence
of of this evil and people like
hannah jones are just sort of smirking
and smiling and
and uh the puppeteer pulling pulling all
the strings
someday whites are going to wake up god
knows when it
is i thought it would have happened by
now i thought they would have gotten
tired of being jacked up like this uh
but apparently not um
so if you're in the if you're if you're
trying to sell
truth if you're trying to point to
here's the truth
we blacks went through four centuries of
oppression
you go through that you when you come
out of it finally as we did in the 60s
you're going to be under developed
they didn't have harvard's for us back
in the days of segregation
we we we could not that that was our big
liability when we walked into freedom
when we stepped into freedom is that we
needed
desperately development education
economic development we needed to join
america become a part of the great
american experiment
and and find parity with all other
groups
that's what we needed what do we
we were so drunk on our power as victims
that we to this day 60 years later
cling to that victimization and we hate
any
minorities who don't if you don't claim
to cling to your victimization you're an
uncle tom
and that's the end of that's the end of
you you're you're cancelled
um so we're we're uh
we're in a chair again the people who
think
they are helping blacks are simply
recolonizing blacks
and now blacks live and
and sort of facilitate white innocence
uh rather than actually move ahead on
their own and become
independent individuals uh functioning
in a free society
we're we don't have the the cultural
history
we never had to deal with freedom when
we were oppressed
now we do freedom is our biggest problem
now not racism
racism is so far down on our list it's
it means
nothing we're afraid of free we don't
know what to do with freedom
how to how to live in it how to make it
work for us
that's where that's our real world
challenge uh and
again uh whites who who are
longing for their innocence and rolling
over for
for black victims they are they now are
the enemy
because they they diminish us to nothing
but but sort of icons that facilitate
their innocence and their power
uh all over again uh i guess
i guess history history does repeat
itself in that sense
so you talked about working in the
social welfare system and obviously in
the 1960s there was a real push
for a sort of racial reparation via
social welfare programs and the great
society programs
uh the idea expressed by lbj is that
well
now the the sort of barriers had been
removed
uh if you had all of the runners at the
start line and one of the runners was 20
yards behind the start line that somehow
we had to find a way to get the person
20 yards behind the start line up to the
start line that's what the social
welfare programs
were for uh but it seems like in many
ways the social welfare programs
actually inhibited the ability for that
runner to ever
catch up and there have been a lot of
minority groups in the united states who
have started off 20 yards behind the
start line compared to white america
many of those minority groups now
routinely outperform white americans in
terms of income
including many groups of african
immigrants nigerian americans for
example outperform
white americans in terms of income so
maybe you can talk a little bit about
social welfare programs
were they it was just well-intentioned
it went wrong or uh was it
what exactly happened with the social
welfare programs why didn't it help
achieve this
very specifically what happened was
because
whites were longing for their innocence
what whites did was literally steal
away from black people agency
over their own fate over their own lives
lbj said put your life in my hands
i will give you an upward bound program
i will expand welfare payments
i will have school busing i will have
public housing
on and on i am the actor i am the agent
of your uplift of your fate
not you you are nothing but a sort of
uh cipher for
uh my innocence
we we blacks hitting not quite knowing
how to handle freedom yet
bought into that and sold our soul
away we put agency we said okay
you be the agent of my uplift
you you're right you did commit you were
ugly you were racist so forth so now you
can redeem yourself by
uplifting me well
when you look at that you're giving away
agency to your own uplift you're putting
it in somebody else's hands
when in all of human history has that
ever worked
you don't give up agency and then think
you're going to somehow miraculously get
get ahead you want agency you we here's
what we should have said
we should have said to white america and
to lyndon johnson
thank you but no thanks you worry about
your innocence
we'll worry about our development we'll
focus as individuals
we will become better educated we will
out compete you
we don't want your help we have our own
honor
our own sense of dignity our own
self-possession
we fail to do that uh the end of
many many many many many and i mean many
individual blacks did
do that and they are doing their
thriving today
and we see them everywhere in every walk
of life
making the point that if one wants to
really take charge of one's fate
and move ahead you're free to do that
today in america you can become
literally the president
if that's what you want to do you can
become the ceo of a major corporation
you can become an artist you can become
a veterinarian you can do whatever you
want
uh and the government will will
never ever under any circumstances be
able to
to do that for you that's a it's a it's
a uh
a kind of sick again symbiotic
bond between that that came out of this
great confession
uh in in the 60s and in both groups got
blinded and made a very a quick
down and dirty deal that's why i think
of lyndon johnson's
great society as a down and dirty deal
he said basically i need the uh
i need the the innocence to to
uh to have legitimacy as the president
and keep legit keep the government
legitimate and so forth i need that
so i don't i'm gonna give you all these
programs even though
they don't do anything whatsoever but
but
teach you corruption embroil you in
corruption
i worked in those programs for three
years
i've never seen so much corruption in my
life it was just wide open
you have to fight for your life i had to
get out of there
or sink into that uh
and i was lucky i was very lucky i had
two good parents and
talked a lot and finally found my way uh
out of there
um yeah but that's what we
we we now have to do we have to get away
from that we have to get away from our
symbiotic relationship to white people
uh i don't want to have a any i want to
be a human being
i want to be a citizen of the united
states i want to relate to all other
human citizens
what your race is i don't care so let's
talk for a second about
why it is that so many you mentioned
there's so many prominent black
americans
with wild levels of success there's so
many black americans who are
middle class and above i know that the
the media tend to portray only
you know poverty and uh and suffering in
the black community
uh you hear politicians routinely talk
about how to be black and america means
to suffer
in america as though the average income
for a black household in the united
states isn't 58 000
or as though the vast majority of of
black americans are living in abject
poverty which simply isn't true
um why is it that we don't see more
black americans
saying exactly what you're saying which
is i've been able to make my way in this
society if you make the right decisions
you can make your way in this society
too
instead it seems like with increased
levels of prominence
uh many black americans speak out more
loudly about how america
is is racist right we've mentioned cohen
and jones several times i mean there's a
person who went to a top university she
obviously
has been granted the keys to the car
over at the new york times he karen at
the washington post who's the daughter
of african immigrants doing the same
thing
uh you see people at the top of the of
the entertainment industry lebron james
does this making hundreds of millions of
dollars uh per year
now barack obama became president of the
united states and then suggested that
america
was still struggling with systemic
racism and uh and made comments about
ferguson missouri which we'll discuss in
a second
uh that at the time i i thought to
myself he's literally ignoring the facts
of the case in order to make these
particular comments
so why is it that we don't see more
prominent black americans say what what
so many prominent members of other
minority races in america say to their
kids and to their compatriots which is
what a great country and we can
absolutely rise in this country
the reason is they don't believe in
themselves
they don't believe in black people
i believe in black people i believe they
should be they should do exactly what
your
what you just said what you're talking
about um that's our only future
you only you only get what you make for
yourself
uh you you uh the the
that's the obligation of freedom is you
have to make something of yourself
but they simply one of the problems
in black american life this comes from
four centuries of oppression
is faithlessness in your group
your group was oppressed that the the
somebody's heel was on their neck
they were denigrated they were
dehumanized
um and part of the
a formerly oppressed person's
struggle is to
have faith in precisely those people
one's own people who come from all of
that
to love them and have faith in them
the biggest problem in black america is
faithlessness
we don't believe in ourselves we don't
believe we'll be able to compete
we be all of the ugly bigotries of of
the white
past we on some secret level where we
don't admit it to ourselves even
believe that and don't and and and
therefore lack the faith to take our
lives into our own hands
and make something and make a life we
say
to protect ourselves that's a fool's
game
this is a racist world a racist society
that's
to work hard and and uh so that's uh
that's a that's for fools
that's in a white man that's those are
uncle toms
white man always has you know believes
in them
uh well you know we
have to face this problem of
faithlessness
and we have to raise our children
ready we have we have to completely
are you reading to your children are you
teaching them are you developing them
intellectually are you developed
developing them
their academic skills their their
interpersonal skills the values
are you building strong independent
people who will be able to be
responsible
for their own advancement are you doing
that
if you're not you're worse than w than
racism
you're contributing to a life of
inferiority and struggle
we have it backwards uh and
um it it it's
it is heartbreaking we we
another problem is that we live in such
an absolutely wealthy society
society is can give us all the figure i
keep hearing is the
last 50 years that america has spent 22
trillion dollars on social programs
that's a lot of bait to tempt me away
from this
this more rigorous self-development and
into the idea that i can
manipulate maneuver game my way ahead
and so forth in a wealthy society you
can do that
um and america will has got the wealth
to continue to dump it on uh people as
he said amazon 10
million dollars they wake up and and uh
give it give that away
well i'm on the wrong side of the fence
i didn't get any of that not a dime they
canceled me
so let's talk about that in just one
second i want to ask you about the
documentary what killed
michael brown that is going to be
available somewhere but apparently not
amazon we'll get to that in just one
second but first
let's talk about censorship on social
media sites and what you can do about it
the left wants to silence and remove any
voices they don't like twitter and
facebook
these were supposed to be open platforms
i don't need their content moderators
acting like the op-ed section of the new
york times
instead of letting those social media
sites revoke your right to free speech
how about revoking their right to your
data
now you could just deactivate all your
social media accounts but that would be
giving the left just what they wanted in
the first place instead
use expressvpn the way i do if you've
ever wondered how free to access sites
like facebook make their money well
they track your searches video history
everything you click on and then they
sell your valuable data
when you use expressvpn you anonymize
much of your online presence by hiding
that ip address
that makes your activity more difficult
to trace and sell to advertisers
an expressvpn could not be easier to set
up you just tap one button on your phone
or computer
and you're now protected expressvpn also
encrypts 100 of your data to help
protect you from hackers and internet
bad guys so
now is the time to say no to censorship
take back your online privacy today
at expressvpn.com by visiting my special
link you get an extra three months of
expressvpn service for free
again that's expressvpn.com ben
expressvpn.com to get started
okay so you've now referred to this
documentary that you made what killed
michael brown i had a chance to watch a
large segment
of it uh last night it is you know
incredibly incisive and uh and
emotionally devastating
um because it really does take on some
very serious issues
so what was the impetus behind making a
documentary about the
michael brown shooting we wanted to
debunk this idea
of victimization as power uh
michael brown the the reason michael
brown would become so
explosive and and
more recently here george floyd and so
forth and others the reason these events
become so explosive
is because they represent
they seem to morally give moral
authority to blacks as victims
they seem to reinforce our whole black
pathology which sees victimization as
our great power and my god a white cop
with a shoots and kills a black teenager
there it is that's that's four centuries
of racism right there
you owe me and i will give grant you
your innocence but you'll have to pay
for it
so all of a sudden everybody the
president of the united states the
attorney general of the united states
everybody is in ferguson missouri uh
anguishing over the
the the shooting of michael brown black
black teenager
well they're there because it just re it
just
flows over with black power
if he if michael brown was really shot
and killed
out of a racial racial animus
then think of all the power that
redounds then to all of black america
we can what we can just sort of work
that we can work that angle for 10 more
years
uh and so all of these events like this
geor
george floyd so forth they're all
they're all this sort of
the this temptation is this uh we
everybody knows
power is to be had in these events who's
going to get the power
and of course blacks are uh here it is
we've now had 60 years of
victimization being our primary source
of power and so
uh anyway we wanted to we wanted to go
in and show
exactly that corruption uh
and and point to some of the damage
that's done
and then we wanted to look toward the
end of the film at some positive
uh activities that are going on in the
black community there are people doing
some miraculous work we
interviewed a pastor and uh who uh uh
has his church
right in the in the woodlawn area the
south side of chicago where the murder
rate is over
over the roof um we talked to former
former drug dealers um we
we uh uh we looked at
in public housing we we looked at all
against
the offshoots of this sort of thing and
with the with the to try to point the
way
uh ahead and uh
i i i particularly like the uh
the end of the film where where we i go
back to my
my father's childhood uh home in
kentucky
and uh we and i remember reminisce
of these people my grandfather was
actually born a slave
not my great-grandfather my literal
grandfather
uh was actually born a slave and and
they
uh came forward in camp nelson kentucky
and uh my father how he
uh from the age of 14 on was on his own
and had to make his way in the world and
teach himself to read and write and and
so i wanted to honor that selfless
struggle
on the part of black americans our
greatness comes from those people they
did it they didn't go around begging for
white good will
they all they wanted was don't
discriminate against me
i don't want to any my father hated the
idea of public housing
thought it was just the ticket to hell
um
he could see that coming and many other
blacks in our neighborhood did
and we rejected it uh but that white
guilt
is is is hard to maybe they rejected it
but do their kids pretty soon
they be they begin to be bought off one
by one by one by one
here's an easier road for you
and you look up in in you're in uh
under the under the power of of people
who are look who
the it's the problem with white guilt
social programs that look
out after white power
white power white innocence and white
power
uh and you become just again a cipher a
means to that
end at the end of the film we try to
really get into that
and i think have some some some moving
moments at least they were moving to me
when
when we filmed them and so now you found
out that uh what amazon won't even
offer the film for for sale is that is
that where things are right now
the they uh sent us a letter
uh that said not only will we not do it
but don't try to resubmit it don't
change the time don't do anything
we don't want it ever
so there was as to make a a statement
certain friends of mine have been
cancelled from twitter
um think tanks are rearranging
themselves
uh and there's again we've got this
uh this whole fun canceling phenomenon
that
that uh i'm going to cancel evil
i'm going to cancel uh that some
perniciousness
uh in the name of the good
well what is what's the good to to
amazon the good
is black black lives matter
which is a well i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna waste time getting into to
what they are but but
i i think they're completely on the
wrong track they
they will keep us mired celebrating
ourselves as victims forevermore
well so now i'm going to ask you to go
on the wrong track there and actually
describe what you think of the black
lives matter movement because obviously
it has
had this massive impact on our politics
and
we've seen corporations going woke
across the country we've seen the nba
decide to dedicate entire
uh sidelines on national broadcast to
their sloganeering
changing the jerseys on the on the back
of the jersey so you can put
the names of people who have allegedly
been unjustly killed
by the police uh you've seen every major
politician
pay lip service to black lives matter
which is a semantically overloaded
phrase i mean it can mean a few things
one the obviously true statement that
black lives matter because they do
uh it can mean the movement which is the
assumption that america's systemically
racist and that black americans are at
unique risk of being murdered in the
united states which
is certainly not true from the police it
may be true statistically but it really
has very little to do
with white americans doing the murdering
unfortunately uh and uh
and then it could mean the black lives
matter organization which is actually
just the neo-marxist front group
um but i want to get your thoughts on
black lives matter which again has
become this sort of tautological
statement
and you have to say it and if you don't
say it then this obviously means that
you're racist
well they break my heart they first of
all make me sad
um to have lived through what i've lived
through and see
uh what black america has stood for and
fought for
uh and i think of my father's generation
and
in earlier
men and women who survived the most
horrific sort of
oppression uh violent murderous
oppression for centuries
and to come to a place and see our young
people
using that history of victimization to
hide
away from the challenges of
freedom that we face today
it's heartbreaking for somebody my age
to see that you finally got a chance
to do anything you want and you
you you all you're going to do is talk
about victimization
well when they when they
talk about systemic racism and so forth
i call it compensatory racism it is a
a faith in racism uh
that we we should an emphasis on on
racism
because the reality is racism has
declined
radically declined it's just not there
anymore
and so we we have to come up with new
terms like systemic and structural
racism and so forth to bring back
that old oppression that we
endured for four centuries that's sad
we now when we bring that back we say
now we know who we really
are as black people that's not who we
really were we were the people who
fought for freedom
and finally won it but we don't get
credit for that
we don't give ourselves credit for that
we we whine
we want we want whites to give us more
junk and of course they're rich
and they can do that and they do do that
um and then and so then we're inflated
in our illusions
and we think uh you know we think people
like me for example are
are just hopeless uh over the hill uncle
toms
um well it's it's again it's
heartbreaking it's sad
it's sad to see young people
sell themselves out that way to to
exhibit that level of faithlessness in
their own
abilities to develop and overcome i want
to see them
see what you i always ask them well
what's your grade point average
what are you doing to develop yourself
black students have the highest dropout
rate and the lowest grade point average
of any student group in america
after 50 years of affirmative action
uh we we we now uh have a bill to pay
we're going to have to pay pay this bill
and uh you know i don't know what
generation will
will finally get there but at some point
whites are going to turn around and say
you you got
we're done we're not enabling you
anymore
enabling black people has has become an
american
habit a reflex um that
that we do again because we just keep
needing wanting this innocence
uh wanting the power that comes from the
legitimacy
that comes from uh from being innocent
uh demonstrably innocent of racism so
we'll give you the
give you more preferences give you this
give you give you give you
uh as you sink as you as you sink into
this faithlessness
uh in yourself well as you can see it's
kind of a stalemate
uh uh that we've got going on here
i'm not sure how it will break i know it
will at some point but
i hope soon sooner than later in a
second
i want to ask you about your opinion of
the obama administration because
obviously we've had a black president
for two terms one two overwhelming
victories and i think you know entered
office with
high hopes by most americans that this
was going to be maybe the final stage in
the transition away from thinking
racially in the country i mean
he sort of campaigned as we're not red
states we're not blue states we're the
united states
i'm both i'm both black and white
obviously in
my own ancestry now i can bring the
country together it didn't end up that
way i want to get your assessment
of the obama administration of barack
and now michelle who's obviously a very
prominent political figure in her own
right
uh in one second first i have to tell
you the amazing presidential election
is almost here we have an incredible day
of programming for you our live stream
starts
on tuesday november 3rd at 3 p.m eastern
12 p.m pacific featuring special guests
live interviews and more
leading up to our evening show we'll be
covering the results with you in real
time it's going to be spectacular
and exciting even better join daily wire
right now get 25
off with code election so you can watch
all of our election coverage live on our
apple tv or
roku app members get our articles at
free access to all of our live
broadcasts and show library
the full three hours of the ben shapiro
show and exclusive reader's past content
available only to daily wire members
if you're considering an all-access
membership you get to join us on all
access live every night for online and
live stream discussions with our hosts
and an amazing online community
you also get not one but two leftist
tears tumblers with your membership
as well as early and sometimes exclusive
access to new daily wire products
so watch the election with us at
dailywire.com get 25
off your daily wire membership with code
election when you sign up today
alrighty so let's talk about the obama
administration and barack obama
uh as i say for for everybody even
people like me who did not vote for
barack obama i thought that he was a
bad candidate uh i thought that he would
be of the radical left
politically um you know i i thought that
he basically campaigned on a bunch of
warmed over sloganeering um but even for
folks like me who didn't vote for barack
obama didn't back him
uh it was obviously uh an inspiring
thing for the united states which is a
majority white country to elect
a black president after our history of
slavery and jim crow like just
that symbol is an inspiring thing it
didn't appear to end that way you look
at the polls of race relations they
really markedly declined during the
obama administration even preceding the
trump administration
uh what do you make of of the obama
administration
of barack obama as a figure and now
michelle obama who's widely perceived to
be
the maybe the future of the democratic
party barack obama was a
was a um
a perfect sort of white fantasy
and he was elected entirely i think
entirely because he was black
america's sim and he was as joe biden
once said
uh he was clean i guess he showers every
day and he spoke
eloquent uh english and so he was
he was in other words he was innocuous
he had no vision for the country that he
ever articulated
uh no set of policies coherent policies
that would
reflect some some important vision for
the country
he just was a nice white a black kid who
who white people realized on some level
wouldn't do much of anything except
be black and be in the white house
so that white america could say
we're innocent of racism we are redeemed
this is our redemption and so it was he
was
obama was just a small player in a white
self-promotional sort of historical
event
um that's all he was again he
he couldn't tell you today what his
vision was for
for society nor could all the white
people who voted for him
they don't know what he stood for no but
he didn't stand for anything that's
again that's the point he he didn't get
a way of get
in the way of his message which is that
i'm
i'm a uh a black person who's going to
be in the
the most powerful man uh in the world
and that's
how innocent america is that's how
wonderful america is racially they've
overcome that shameful history of
slavery and so forth and now they have a
black man in the white house
aren't they very aren't they wonderful
what does it mean in reality
is are blacks somehow uh more equal
today than they were before
uh have they somehow caught up with
whites in in uh
economically educationally otherwise
no nothing
uh except that white whites can say we
we're innocent of racism we we elected a
black
a black president so i mean i think he
has to be seen
in in the context of white guilt he's
he's a white guilt president
uh beginning in the end michelle
same i don't see i don't see much
difference there they
they that's the game they both play
um just a little bit every now and then
of edginess around the race issue just
to keep their
bona fides with with militant blacks
but no leadership no sense of of what
ails black america how it has to be
overcome
none of that so now i want to ask you
your opinion
of the of the trump administration
there's been a lot of talk about racism
uh surrounding president trump and uh
the supposed innate racism of the
american people
uh in electing trump in 2016.
joe biden has suggested that he's
running almost entirely to repudiate
trump's personal
racism what what do you make of trump as
a figure trump's election
uh and uh and the trump administration i
think that trump is pretty much what he
claims to be
uh you know he's he he wants to fix
things
he's a kind of mr fixit president and he
does he's fixed
any number of any number of things but
he has no he has no uh he is vulnerable
because the left in america
uh is is driven by white guilt defined
by white guilt
and and you could that couldn't be
farther away from where donald trump is
he just is not
in this sort of the
he he offers no innocence to white
america
uh and therefore he's a racist and he's
a bigot and he's he's a
regression to oppression and he wants
and so forth and so on
um but the fact is he's just a pragmatic
a pragmatic sort of
unimaginative uh president who
who really does fix our trade relations
uh with the chinese who
changes look at what he's done in the
middle east
uh really marvelous marvelous things
that
the obama administration never got close
to doing
um but again he has no vision of white
innocence uh and that's what it that's
what the left wants today
and that's what a much of america still
wants today
is this this sort of white innocence and
uh
uh so i don't know whether we we
have to elect another obama or not but
uh
at some point there will be there will
be blacks who are themselves as human
beings and
and who represent um the politics
political point of view
of the whole nation yeah in a second i
want to ask you a couple final questions
starting with whether you think that
white guilt or uh
or black victimization is going to
alleviate first which
which side in this sort of symbiotic
racial relationship you've talked about
is going to change its behavior first
but if you actually want to hear shelby
steals answers then you have to head on
over to dailywire.com
you can subscribe over there and hear
the end of our conversation
well shelby steele as you know i'm a big
fan of your work people should go out
watch the documentary they should
purchase
all of your books including white guilt
really appreciate your time it's been an
honor
well it's been an honor to be here i
i've admired you're
you are your own man i i admire you
hey thanks so much appreciate it
[Music]
the ben shapiro show sunday special is
produced by mathis glover
executive producer jeremy boring our
technical director is austin stevens and
our assistant director is pavel wydowsky
associate producer nick sheehan our
guests are booked by caitlin maynard
editing is by jim nicholl audio is mixed
by mike coromina hair and makeup is by
nika geneva
title graphics are by cynthia angulo the
ben shapiro show sunday special is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2020.